[Music]
fans have waited decades to see their
favorite JSA characters come alive on
the big screen the
day was actually the first superhero
team in the DC Universe in the team you
have senior versus the new recruits
Carter Hall is the leader of JSA better
known as Hawkman he is a warrior through
and through brace yourself
Dr Fate he has power to teleport foresee
the future be prepared
Adam Smasher and Cyclone they're
newcomers to the JSA
you can modify his molecular structure
so he can get bigger heavier and
stronger the Cyclone has the ability of
aerokinesis she can manipulate wind
patterns
to tell you I'm excited is an
understatement I cannot wait to
introduce the JSA to the world
Black Adam in Sims October 21st book
tickets now
my son sacrificed his life to save me
but a curse
born
out of Rage
[Music]
this Loose Cannon needs to be locked
down before innocent people start
getting hurt
it's been asleep for five thousand years
find us a cell that can hold them
they'll take care of the breath who's on
the team
I didn't bring a passport we don't need
passports
to the Justice Society
I got him we're here to negotiate your
peaceful surrender
I'm not peaceful
nor do I Surrender
here we go
I kneel before no one
[Music]
come here to seek Justice
of exact Revenge
[Music]
I never said I was a hero
[Music]
you believe you are not worthy
fate does not make mistakes
[Music]
[Music]
be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
[Music]